Welcome everybody to another business Q&A.
I'm excited to be back.
We're going to play some League of Legends.
Let me adjust my camera there a little bit.
We're going to play some League of Legends,
answer your business questions, and here we go.
It's a happy Tuesday.
Ready to continue our winning streak.
Rishi Cup TV, back in the house, welcome back.
I'm grateful to be in the house.
What's in the cup today?
How's everybody doing?
Today I am really a cup of excited.
I feel like Evan, I need to think
of more interesting things to say, but I am.
I am, I'm just a cup of excited to be here.
I'm also drinking my ustedo, Spanish coffee.
This is a trend, just like our winning streak.
Oh wow, alright, well let's continue it on.
I hope we don't disappoint there on that.
I love it, yeah, I just had my water.
I had my vitamins, I got my water.
I'm going to do some entrepreneur stuff.
We got J.R.I.'s in the game.
We're queuing up to try to find a match.
Let's do it, let's get to some questions.
You don't have any tea today, no messages on your tea?
You know, I have this new, I haven't said it yet,
but J. brought me some new awesome Nettle Tea,
and Nettle Tea is good for controlling allergies.
Got it.
But there's no messages on this one,
so I'd rather have the health benefit over the message.
The wisdom.
Yeah, so we'll see, maybe the next batch.
Maybe the next batch.
Rishi Cup can come up with the quote,
wisdom, Zen wisdom of the day.
Well, it makes me think with this whole cup thing,
I got up, maybe I need to create my own tea product.
Tea bag wisdom.
Tea bag love.
Type that in there, let's see, tea bag wisdom.
Ooh, Google search, and let's find something quick.
Tea bag wisdom, there you go.
Open up to infinity, and you become infinity.
There you go.
All right.
I feel like we should start
with the Rishi quote of the morning.
That would be fun.
I'm so not someone who like, I love quotes absolutely,
but I don't follow quotes on Twitter or anything.
Do you do that?
Is there quotes that you daily look at every day?
There'll be some that we, like, I'll post a bunch.
I'll post some that I find interesting and inspiring
on my Twitter account and Facebook.
But it's okay, we don't have to use those ones.
I like, I don't know, we'll see.
Let's see if you feel inspired tomorrow
for a Rishi quote of the morning.
Rishi quote of the morning.
Coffee and quotes with Rishi.
Sounds good.
All right.
Cool.
Well, let's do it.
Okay, let's do it.
First question is coming from Avinash.
And Avinash says, hey, Evan, I'm really stuck
in my career and life, not knowing where to head next.
And worse, not knowing how to find out.
I need guidance to break free and come out of it.
Could you help me?
Okay.
So, I'm excited to hear what you have to say
about this, Evan, actually.
Because I was thinking about some practical skills
to get unstuck.
And I think that a lot of us feel stuck.
And it's a, I think it's definitely complex.
But I think one of the first things I would say,
just on a practical level, is, you know,
when you're stuck, you feel frustrated
because you want to see more momentum.
And so that can, in a lot of us,
that can create this kind of urgency to go and do.
And, you know, there's nothing wrong with that.
And I think that could be, at different times,
the right strategy.
But I was just, the first thing that came to mind
is when you're feeling stuck,
one of the best things I think you can do
is just kind of like get still,
turn out all the noise,
and I don't know if you like to journal,
I don't know if you like to just sit
and ponder and contemplate.
I don't know if you like to pray or meditate.
But like, there's just different things you can do
to kind of connect more deeply.
And I think sometimes you get stuck
when you're kind of running without a vision,
running without clear purpose,
you're not connected to who you are.
And so, I don't know,
I just think it might seem counterproductive
to not just go out and do something,
but I think it is important that before you do
that next thing, to get still
and kind of get refocused on who you are,
what you want to do, and kind of your why.
Like, why am I going to do this,
whatever this next thing that I'm going to do is.
So, those are some hopefully practical steps.
For me, I think it starts with,
do you have something that you want to do?
Do you have, you know, I've always wanted to X,
I've always wanted to go salsa dancing,
I've always wanted to launch a website,
or I've always wanted to build an app,
or I've always wanted to play guitar,
or whatever it is, even if it doesn't make sense.
You know, I would never have thought
that I would invest in and later acquire
North America's largest salsa dancing school
when I first walked into a salsa dancing college, right?
Yeah.
I would never have expected that.
But I wanted to learn how to dance.
You know, it was just something interesting to do.
And at the same time as I did that,
I did, you know, 20 other things
that I didn't continue with.
And that's okay.
So it's finding within yourself,
is there something that you want to do,
and then finding some small way to get started
without putting so much expectations on it.
I think people set this, that set themselves up for failure
because they put too high expectations on themselves.
Like, I'm going to go in and that first class
has to be amazing, and this has to be
my next business opportunity,
and this has to be the thing that I'm going to do
for the rest of my life, or I'm not going to do it.
So there's so much pressure on that first day
that then you quit and move on to something else.
Well, that could have been an amazing thing.
And so, for the people who know what they want to do,
for sure, then go out and chase that.
You know, and you may have a whole bunch
of limiting beliefs around why you can't,
but it doesn't sound like it's the case here.
It doesn't know what the next thing is to do.
So I'd start by thinking about
what are some of the things that I've always wanted to do
that I have an interest in.
You know, I did this when I sold my business.
When I sold my first company,
I didn't, there was this big hole in my heart.
You know, like, what do I do next?
It was a great problem to have.
I'm not complaining about it,
but it was still a problem in that
I didn't have a clear plan of what I wanted to do next.
It was, I don't want to say depressed,
but you know, as someone who likes having plans
and likes knowing what they're doing,
that was a not great place to be in for me.
And one of the things I wanted to learn about
was venture capital.
You know, I never needed to raise venture capital
for my company, but I wanted to learn about it,
and I ended up connecting with a venture capital company
and learning the ropes,
and I was there for a couple years,
and it was interesting, and I enjoyed it.
At the same time, I started doing, you know,
more salsa dancing, getting more active in it.
I started doing public speaking,
and I did a whole bunch of other stuff
that I don't remember that didn't stick.
And so it's just exploring the things
you've always wanted to do in a small way
and seeing how much you like it
without putting the pressure on it having to work out.
Just like if you go on a first date with someone,
it doesn't have to be that person you're going to marry yet.
You know, you're going to set yourself up for failure
if you have to decide after the first date
if you're going to marry somebody.
If you have no idea, you don't know what you want,
like there's zero inclination,
there's nothing you've always wanted to do,
even to try, you feel totally lost,
then I would say just start exposing yourself
to more opportunities.
Just say yes, the whole bunch of stuff.
Adopt a mindset of that you'll try anything once.
It's a good mindset to have in general.
Try anything once, whether it's a new activity,
whether it's going to a new place,
whether it's trying a new food,
you're unhappy and feel stuck
because you're doing the same thing
over and over and over and over again.
So saying yes to things,
even if you judge them initially as being not for you
and having no interest in it,
just saying yes and trying things
until you find something that you do
want to go back and do it again.
I really love that spicy Indian food.
Let me go back and try some more of it
or maybe I'll go cook some of it on my own
and that leads you down this path.
And you'll find that you hate a lot of the stuff
or it's not interesting for you.
You don't like snowboarding or whatever it is that you try.
So be open, say yes.
Adopt a mindset of trying anything once
until you find the thing that you want to do
again and again and again and again because you love it.
That's what I got.
Great.
So I have Teemo jungle.
J-R-I's has Ryze mid.
We have somebody in our game with us
who also has smite on so they want to go jungle.
That's weird, I don't know how that's gonna happen.
Anyway, we'll see what happens.
I like that question, thank you.
Thank you for writing in and I hope you're okay.
Awesome.
All right.
Next question is coming from Ben
and I was gonna say last thing, I don't think I'm going to.
Ben says he's 21 years old, college student.
Started as a freelance animator six months ago
and right now he's making about $200 a month
using freelancer.com for contests.
And he's been to one networking event to test the waters
and he's happy to see that many people were interested
about having animated videos on their website
but he didn't pick up any sales because he just started
and he did not have as much impressive stuff to show them.
Now he's almost done putting together his business cards,
demo reel website and he's looking to be hitting
networking events hard to get sales.
Hold on, we have an attention to attention.
Fire protection.
We always, well I guess it's a monthly thing, right?
We can expect it once a month.
Yeah.
Well here's some nice beeps.
We'll have to work around the beeps.
Okay.
Nothing yet.
I don't remember this happening every month
but I guess it does.
It said monthly so I mean it's a good thing.
I think last time it happened during our gratitude stream,
didn't it or was it during the league game?
No, it happened here, this is like the second time.
Attention, attention.
May I have your attention please?
This is Arthur Fire Protection.
We will now be conducting our monthly fire alarm testing
so please disregard any fire alarm signals
you may encounter.
Thank you.
All right, well it looks like a guy is playing,
trying to play jungle at the same time as me
which is not great.
I don't know what's happening.
Hilarious.
I queued up as jungle.
Soon as time.
All right, well Alex is here to help alleviate.
Whoa, don't break it, don't break it.
All right, okay yes, we'll see.
So networking events, he's got all this stuff.
He's going to go to networking events.
And then.
Okay, so now he has five questions.
He said it's fine if you want to do rapid fire responses
but he's got five questions he'd love to hear from you.
And just a heads up, actually Ben is,
it's super cool because in one of our previous episodes
we had a funny conversation.
I don't know if you guys listening remember
when we were talking about don't steal your mama's car.
He then went out and created a meme from that live chat
and it was really clever.
So don't sell your mama's car
was the meme that he created.
So anyway, that was cool that he gave value there.
Oh, it's don't sell your mama's car.
I heard don't steal your mama's car.
I think I, yeah, I think I thought it was steal
but it's sell, don't sell your mama's car.
Got it.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
All right, let's do it, questions.
So what are we starting off with?
Yeah, do you want me to in this case answer them rapid fire
or do you want me to just give them to you
and you can do rapid fire?
Rishi brings the value too.
Let's do it, let's go one more time.
I love Evan's confidence in my value.
All right, how should I approach someone
I have never met before?
Should the conversation be about me or about them?
All right, well, actually I'm just gonna say
that you already approached Evan and myself
the way that I would have done it
if it was wanting to kind of create opportunity
for conversation and that was you added value.
You listened to something that we did
and then you created a really funny meme
that showed your skills but added value.
And so I feel like that would be a great thing
to keep doing in terms of creating opportunities
is whatever you're doing, whether it's a conversation
about you or someone else, more importantly just add value.
Yeah, nobody wants to be sold to
but everybody wants solutions to their problems
and the only way to find out those problems
is to listen to them.
Yes, nice.
You said that yesterday, Evan.
That's all I do here, I just rehash my old answers.
It was good, but about selling,
we were talking about selling yesterday
and you were saying too many people just sell,
they don't listen.
Yeah, I got you.
Okay, number two, how should they pay me?
Hourly, lump sum up front, lump sum at the end or in stages?
I would just say it's totally dependent
on the relationship, whether you're a contractor
or you're gonna end up being employed for a company,
it's gonna depend on the relationship
but in the meantime, I would definitely,
since you're already doing contract work on freelancer,
I would start talking to other people doing what you do
and see what's worked for them in terms of setting it up.
I would definitely not do lump sum at the end.
It's too easy to get ripped off by a client
so that I would immediately take off the table.
In terms of setting the deal,
ideally you get paid up front for everything.
Doesn't typically happen in the industry.
You would have to really command their respect
to be able to do it.
I would think if you're at the starting stages of this,
I'd be looking at doing half up front
and half upon delivery or a third up front,
a third upon approval of concept
and then a third at the end.
You don't want to, let me just buy my stuff here.
It's too risky.
It's too risky to just get it all at the end
in case they bail on you.
You've done a ton of work and it's super unlikely
that they're going to want to pay you everything up front.
But hey, if you can get that, that's a solid deal.
Nice.
Okay.
Number three, what type of business do you think
would benefit from having new animated videos
produced for them on a regular basis?
Literally my answer would just be any type of businesses.
It's interesting.
There's opportunity even with some businesses
that you would think are unlikely to want your services
may really be open to it.
You never know what stage a business is in
if they're trying to do new things.
And obviously video is huge for most businesses
at this stage.
So I wouldn't exclude anyone from potential clients.
I love it.
J-Rise and I got a kill.
Good job.
Woo, woo, woo, woo.
Loving that.
I think much more than a specific type of industry
to target, you're looking for a mindset.
So I want somebody who cares about online marketing,
who values it, who's done some work already
on their website.
Maybe not have done video before, but do a lot of,
you know, are a little bit more socially minded.
Like they're active on Facebook.
They're active on Twitter.
They care about their brand.
And that could be any industry.
So I wouldn't just, oh, I missed that guy.
Holy cow.
It's much more the mindset than just the industry
that he's looking for.
Great.
All right, number four.
What positions at a company are responsible
for the decision-making around animated videos?
What was the question?
Again, what positions at a company?
Okay.
Yeah, like who's the one who's deciding
if there should be animated videos or not, you know?
Right.
And I do think, again, you just never know
until you just start knocking on doors.
I mean, you could say the obvious,
like who's in charge of social media,
who's in charge of some of the marketing
and that type of thing, but you just never know
if maybe a certain department is specifically
trying to do something new.
And so you just never know,
but I guess maybe the obvious would be marketing
and that sort of thing.
Yeah, again, it's more the mindset of the person.
Marketing is an easy one,
but it could also be just internal communications.
It could be a company has a board meeting coming up
and they want a video to showcase their results.
It's much more about the mindset of the person
than it is the specific position they're in
because you could just say, hey, okay,
anybody who's in marketing, I'm gonna target,
and maybe that's gonna be a good fit,
but I look at a good buddy of mine
who's built a million dollar business plus
in the video production world,
you know, traditional videos, but also work videos.
And most of his stuff is internal communications.
It's not externally focused.
It's just for people to explain their message
to other people inside the company.
So you never know.
The thing that I would add to it,
which maybe I add to the last question,
is I would also try to pick an industry
or a company that you like.
If I have my choice of companies to work for or work with,
there would be someone that I know something
a little bit about and I like their business
as opposed to just any random company
because you'll get along better.
You know, if you love food,
you'll do really well with restaurants, right?
If you can go in and talk about their food
and how much you love food and what they're all about,
you'll do a lot, whoa, am I gonna die, am I gonna die?
I am not gonna die.
You'll have more fun and they'll be more receptive
to your message than if you're going in trying to sell
to stockbrokers and you have zero interest in stocks.
So if you had to pick, if trade show's gonna be your motto
and you have to pick what you're gonna do,
I would try to pick something where you have
a little bit of passion and domain expertise around too.
Would you think at this stage, Ben,
it is important for him to also be thinking about values
and those things as well besides the actual industry?
Sure, yeah, I mean, it starts with you understanding
what your values are and then bringing that to the business.
And they'll be companies that you naturally
are attracted to, you know, you've bought their products
before, you've worked with some of the people before,
maybe as a client, as a customer, you know,
think about the people you have a great relationship with
who have businesses, whether it's a real estate agent
that you love working with or, you know, whoever it is,
somebody that you get along with well
and you feel like you share similar kinds of values,
that's gonna be really important.
Oh, there it is.
There it is, there it is.
I'm grateful for Alex to help me,
although it doesn't seem to be working.
Is it working, Alex?
The button's broken.
The button's broken?
We pushed it too many times.
You pushed it too many times?
Well, that's awkward.
You guys get to hear some amazing beeps.
Oh, there we go.
I'm done.
Thank you, Alex.
Much love, Alex.
We're creating a stressful morning for Alex.
All right, what's next?
Great, did you get to finish your thought?
Yeah, yeah, I liked it.
That was a good thought.
I liked it too.
All right, last question is,
should I wear a t-shirt that says, I am Ben,
I make cartoons, benscartoons.com?
I like it.
Go ahead, Rishi.
Hey, I mean, there's nothing wrong with doing that
if you're gonna be going to like a big event or something,
if it helps identify you and the mass amount of people,
but I wouldn't say it's unnecessary,
but if you can do that for an event,
there's nothing wrong with that.
Just don't go out and try to make like thousands of them
and then they sit in your closet.
I have to shout him out too,
because I do know that he's from San Fran,
so I just have to plug that the West Coast
is the best coast.
That is a huge lie.
I'm sorry.
But we do love our West Coast friends.
We do love our West Coast friends.
So I like the creativity.
I think having something,
like my initial reaction was to laugh.
I think you have to do something
that fits your personality.
It sounds like this is, and it's a fun talking point.
So there's a lot,
you don't have to have t-shirts to have success at events,
but I like it.
I like the flare.
It's different.
Absolutely.
That's it then Evan for our San Francisco buddy.
Oh, is that it?
Okay.
That's the end of,
That was the question.
Hold the five questions.
We have,
Alex is back.
The game is getting so hot.
The game is getting so hot that
our answers are on fire Rishi.
Our answers are on fire.
I liked it.
Yeah.
It's the new sound effects in League of Legends.
You know, it's this fire alarm.
Cool.
All right.
Well, good luck Ben.
Right Evan?
Good luck.
Team we just got a double kill.
Excited about that.
Good.
Okay.
Next question coming from
Joshua.
Joshua has a couple of questions as well.
He says, I am most grateful for your quick response.
It was just a perfect impression.
I think this might've been somewhat,
you might've responded to a previous question.
It's my pleasure to meet your company.
Your YouTube videos are just woo, bravo.
Thanks for taking your time to read my mail.
Very big thanks.
Wait, how did you spell woo?
How is woo spelled?
I'm curious.
Why are you asking?
I'm just curious.
I like the dramatic emphasis you put on it.
And now I'm wondering, how did he spell it?
Well, it's so funny because I'm looking back.
I read woo, but it's probably really whoa
because I just noticed there's an H at the end.
Okay, so I liked it.
So he spelled it, he spelled W-O-O-O-H.
Whoa.
So it probably should've said,
your YouTube videos are just whoa, bravo.
All right, I like that.
Because only Evan can correct my spelling.
No, I wasn't trying to cry, I was just curious.
I really liked the love that you put into that.
So I was curious as to how it was spelled.
No, that's great.
So he's super grateful and excited.
And so he has three follow-up questions.
Okay.
So let's maybe do this rapid.
I'm working a lot of these multi-part questions today.
I know.
Number one, do I have to obtain
my patent registration first,
making headway for production of my product?
So this is in regards to,
he asked a question previously about patenting.
Do you have to obtain your patent registration first
before making headway on the production of my product?
And I would say no.
You can, I mean, you obviously wouldn't wanna go
on the market without the patent,
but you can go forward with the production.
Is that correct, Evan?
Yeah, as long as it's not commercially available for sale,
then you can get a patent.
Once you're already selling it,
then you can only patent improvements that are made to it.
Okay.
He says, number two, the patent registration in Nigeria,
does it have jurisdiction over other countries,
or do I get patent registration to any country
I wish to do business in?
Ha ha, I wish, I wish.
Yeah.
So what happens is you can get a provisional patent
that gives you international exposure
or coverage protection for one year,
in which you have that one year to commercialize.
And those are relatively cheaper
than getting a full patent, and it gives you a year.
So that's your chance to see, hey, this is my invention,
you know, does it make money, can I, is it gonna work?
Should I keep going with it?
After that, sometimes you can get an extension on it
for another year, but really after that,
you have to, you have to,
I'm just making the decision here,
you have to get it in each country.
Every country has fees,
and they're annual maintenance fees, too.
So you have to pay every year for that patent to be alive
in your, in whatever country you wanna go to.
And different countries have different rates,
and yeah, you have to pay every year.
So I don't know what the rate in Nigeria is,
but you could cover Nigeria, but then somebody in,
Ghana could go and do it,
or somebody in America could go and do it
using your exact patent.
And it happens a lot, because for a patent to happen,
you have to make your invention publicly known.
So you have to tell people
what it is exactly that you're doing.
So that makes it easy for somebody to copy what you're doing
if you don't have the protection.
So yeah, it's a big deal.
So you have that one-year window
to really go out and do something special.
Hope it works, man.
Patents are, patents are, really,
and I also think, like, do you need a patent?
Depends on what you're trying to do.
Patents are really,
patents really just give you the ability to sue.
It doesn't mean people aren't gonna do it.
People aren't gonna steal your idea,
but if they do, you could sue them.
And so you're not actually probably gonna sue them.
But if you wanna sell to a big company, as an example,
then that's a, a patent is a great way
to be able to protect your intellectual property.
Yeah, cool.
And then the last question is, it says,
if I sell my product in Nigeria to a particular company,
can I still sell it to another company
in African countries or, like, America?
If he sells the product in Nigeria,
can he still sell it in other countries?
Is that the question?
Right, so if he has a patent for it in Nigeria,
you know, does that limit him to sell
to companies in Nigeria, or can he go outside
to other African countries or, like, America?
Yeah, the patent won't make,
the patent is just to defend it.
It doesn't mean that you can't go out.
Okay.
But, you know, the only thing to think about is that,
any trade regulations, those kinds of things,
you can't just import, or you can't just export
any product to the U.S., it has to,
it has to, they might have laws around it,
they definitely have taxes around it,
that kind of stuff you have to figure out,
but the patent has nothing to do with your ability
to sell it in a market.
Cool.
All right, and that's it.
Good luck.
And good luck.
Someone said good luck to you the day,
and I was, like, offended, I'm like, oh boy.
They said good luck to you, and you were offended?
Somewhat, well, I realized that the reason good luck
kind of hits me differently is that it somewhat
has this, like, I know when you say it, it doesn't,
but it has this thing of, like, good luck,
like, I don't know why, maybe that's an American thing,
but I feel like when you say good luck to somebody,
it can have another tone of, like, you know,
have fun trying that, that's really not gonna work.
So sad.
That could be an American thing, though, I'm realizing.
Dated American thing.
Yeah, nevermind, moving on.
Okay, we actually got a question in the live chat going on.
Okay.
So Optisourcebook says, question, you got me thinking,
and this could be related to the previous question,
so let's see, relaunch is so much harder than I think.
I have a company that has been with me since 1994,
minus the eight years on hold.
He said in person at convention, don't worry,
I will support you, I have had,
I am having a real hard time now
because everyone wants analytics
and everyone is downgrading,
so I must make him eat his words.
He sent me three ads.
So should I charge him for the three ads at full price,
half off, or free?
Part of me wants to give him the three ads free,
but that's a lot of money,
but nothing compared to what it costs
to advertise an organization
or having a booth at an exhibit.
I think this is in regards to the question with,
you know, going out and kind of the freelance question
from the animator, I think this might be in regards to that.
So, question is about ads, selling three ads
for full price, half off, or free.
Do you have enough information for this, Evan,
or do I need to get more?
Because I know it's a little bit hard for me to follow.
I'm confused, like she has a magazine or what?
What's she selling ads for?
Okay, yeah, please put that in the chat.
I'm reading now.
It sounds like she's trying to get the business going.
She's been, the business has been on hold.
I still don't know what specifically the ads are for,
but it sounds like she's coming out of a,
kind of a latent period in her business,
and now it's relaunching.
And so the question is, when you're in that place
of relaunch, should you give people deals?
Or, you know, should you do it for half as much or for free?
Like, what's the best strategy when you're trying
to get things off the ground again?
Okay.
But I'm still waiting for more information
about what the ads would be.
I just, I mean, I would want to know more,
and specific to the ads, I don't know,
like, there are particulars definitely
that would influence this, but I'd say anytime you're back
in the beginning stages of wanting to get momentum,
there will be somewhat of a compromise,
because you have to reestablish yourself
to a certain extent, and so I think there must be
at least some willingness to be flexible,
so that you can start getting momentum again.
She says, I have a book that has gone all over the world.
You know, to start.
Yeah.
So Optisource, if you could just tell us
what specifically the ads are for.
All right.
Evan, do you have anything, an input at this point?
I mean, if I'm looking to restart a business,
I would look at, one, can I connect with old clients
that know me, like me, trust me, you know,
I've worked with before, so that can,
so I can, you know, hopefully get a quick boost back in.
I would also try to look at why it didn't work before.
Like, why did you start the business?
Like, why did you stop it?
Is there anything that we learned from that,
so you don't do the same thing as you did before,
and, you know, did you stop it because you were bored,
or you, you know, you didn't have the passion anymore,
or, you know, whatever the reason was,
just so that you don't make those same mistakes again.
But you've started this business already.
I try to learn from that success.
Without, you know, knowing the specifics,
that's kind of general advice that hopefully can help.
Okay.
Yeah, it says the, yeah, I'm gonna actually take the time
to read more of your comments off the source,
so I'm gonna come back around
if I can find a more helpful way to answer your question.
That sound good to you, Evan?
Yep.
Okay.
Next question comes from Song.
Hello there, I'm Song from Malaysia.
I want to know if it's possible to start
a travel agency business with zero experience.
Do you have advice or tips for me?
Thank you very much, have a nice day.
So, a travel agency business, I don't think would be
unlike any other business in that to start,
I would at least want to have some knowledge
of the industry, so I wouldn't just like, you know,
do these huge, big, make these huge, giant steps
in launching your business, I would do some testing,
I would do some researching, I would be maybe working
part-time for a travel agency so that you can start
to get some background and experience.
So, I don't think it's wrong to just start on some level,
but I wouldn't start on a level that's so big
that you find out after you start to start a business,
you find out after you start getting experience
that you're not, you don't love it,
or that you don't have enough knowledge to make it work.
But yeah, I mean, I think people do start businesses
all the time without a lot of experience.
What do you think, Evan?
Well, like we keep talking about over and over
and over on the channel, your success in business
will be from providing value.
The challenge is if you don't have,
you can have passion for industry,
you can have passion for traveling,
but if you don't know the business,
you have zero experience, then it's gonna be hard
for you to provide value in the early stages,
and so it's gonna be hard for you
to have success as an entrepreneur.
That doesn't mean you have to work in the industry
for, you know, forever, and you can be,
try to do something in a new way
that hasn't been done before, which is all awesome.
Just that if you wanna have success,
and you don't know the industry,
it's gonna be hard for you to make it.
So that's what I would be, I would be looking
for trying to get some experience while doing my own thing,
whatever that, you know, whatever that own thing
looks like for you, like what do you love
about the travel agency, what's a unique spin
that you can bring to it, and try to get a job
where I'm learning.
Maybe you wanna be like the travel agent themselves,
maybe you wanna be a travel blogger,
maybe you wanna, you know, report on hotels and do reviews.
There's a lot of different ways that you can spin it.
But just remembering that if you wanna have success
as an entrepreneur, you have to bring value,
and that typically comes from having some sort
of experience to know what value is.
So, maybe you're there yet, maybe you're there,
you already know, but maybe you don't,
and you gotta do a little bit more work to figure it out.
Great.
Next question is coming from, how's the game going, Ed?
We are losing 24 to 33.
I am six and four, so I have a winning record,
but team is losing overall, so we'll see,
we'll see if we can turn this thing around.
Turn the beat around, is that how it goes?
It's like, is that how it goes?
That's way before my time, I don't know where
that came from, but.
That was disco, so.
It inspired a song.
That's great.
All right.
Next question is coming from Jared.
Jared.
Yes, and Jared. What's up, Jared?
Hi, Evan, I just saw one of your videos
on how to start your own clothing line.
If you see this, I would gladly like for you
to message me back with my design I created a year ago.
I stopped developing it for a while
and now I wanna go back and work on it.
It's a fitness clothing line called Go Strong.
Go Strong.
Yeah, so.
There is no, on this particular message,
there is no link to his design.
I'm not exactly sure what he,
you know, maybe he sent you another message
that I'm not seeing, but it's not here,
but I think, yeah.
I wanna give value.
I guess my value would just be,
I would like to see your clothing line.
Okay, so he didn't, so there's no design attached there.
He's just asking to know.
Yeah, he was inspired by your video.
He would love if you, you know,
it says message me back with my design,
so I think that was a typo, but I don't know.
Okay.
You wanna give any feedback for aspiring clothing designers
or anything like that?
Any feedback for aspiring clothing designers
or I know that he already saw the video,
so I'm sure he already gave great value there.
Yeah, so one, I think it's great
to reach out to influencers.
I think it's great to have people, you know,
use, hopefully get their audience
and have them endorse you and they like it
and, you know, can spread the message
if they have some kind of influential circle.
You know, I don't know that my channel's really known
for being a fashion channel,
so you might wanna target other people
who are more kinda tastemakers in the fashion world.
I'm curious also as to why he stopped.
I'm always curious why people stop and then start
and if it's the right thing to do.
Like, is it, do you regret that you stopped
or is this just a fallback plan
and you're not actually that interested in it?
So you don't make the same mistakes again.
Like, if it's been a year since you got that business going,
why now and what are you gonna do differently
this time around so that it works,
that you're actually gonna stick with it,
that you're gonna put in the hustle and the effort.
So it's always something that I'm curious by
when people are restarting businesses.
What do you typically see in that phase?
This goes back to Optisource in the chat
because she's in a position of relaunching.
What do you typically see of it in that,
when people are in that stopping and then they restart?
What's going on there usually?
I think the main thing is something has to change.
If you're not gonna do,
so the reason why people would do it, there's a mix.
Sometimes it's regret,
sometimes they wish they just stuck with it
and now they wanna make sure
that they do it right this time.
Sometimes, going to attack, no.
Sometimes it's just because they have nothing else to do.
Sometimes it just, they're not happy
with the way things are going in their life
and like, you know what, I was kinda happy
when I was doing that business so I'm gonna get back to it.
But the key thing being each time
that it's something that, again, stop working,
you stop doing it, so something has to be different.
Something has to be different this time around
that didn't happen last time, so what is that?
It's like getting back together with an ex, you know?
Like something has to, there's a reason why you broke up.
Why did you break up, right?
And how do you get, what's gonna change?
Not that it can't work, it's great.
Like it can definitely work, just it can't work
the same way that you tried last time.
Because you guys broke up for a reason.
So something has to change.
You broke up with your business for a reason.
Something has to change, so what's gonna change?
And some people are hyper aware of that
and it's great and they go off and they make the changes
and other people don't think that way
and that's gonna be really hard
to get to where you wanna go
if you don't make the realization.
And a follow up to that, Evan,
when have you been able to say,
because sometimes it is hard to let an idea go,
it is time to stop and just go on to something else.
When have you known it's time to,
yeah, this is, you know, time to push stop on this
and restart on something new?
When I don't love it anymore.
That should always be the metric.
If you stop loving it,
and even if it is having some financial success,
if you stop loving it, then you should sell it
or hire somebody to be able to do it with you.
But if you still love it
and you feel you're gonna live with regret,
then you have to find a way to keep going.
Even if it means taking the job
and doing something else in the meantime
to kind of pay your bills and get by
and continue to learn.
But when you stop loving something,
then that's, for me, is always the point
where you wanna quit and move on.
Quitting isn't necessarily a bad thing.
Quitting on something that you love
and is your dream is a bad thing,
but quitting on something
that you don't have the passion for anymore is great.
It's a good decision.
You wanna quit on that stuff.
So I've quit on a lot of stuff.
Big stuff and little stuff.
Because I've tested a whole bunch of stuff.
So that, for me, is always the dividing line.
I'm sure you've made a video on that before,
but it'd be a great video to hear.
Because the entrepreneurs are always like,
don't stop hustling.
But actually, that wouldn't be the truth.
In your case, there's been lots of times you said,
no, it's time to quit this or it's time to quit there.
That.
I'm sure there's a video on it out there already.
Yeah, and I agree with the don't quit mantra in general.
It's a good rule.
And I don't want people to twist it the wrong way now.
It's definitely a good thing.
I think a lot of people just quit too soon.
And I think that's why that's become such a mantra
in the entrepreneur world.
Because most people do quit too soon.
They give up on their idea.
They don't have success.
And it's hard.
You know how hard it is to be an entrepreneur.
It's a hard thing to do.
The worst case scenario, think of that, it's worse than that.
I love it when you say that.
The worst case, what do I say?
Whatever you think is the worst thing that could happen.
Oh, it's gonna be worse.
It's worse than that.
Yeah, that's true.
It is, it's true.
It is true.
This is why you don't want me to do quotes.
I sometimes mess them up.
Hey, we won, they surrendered.
Good game, good game.
Easy.
Yeah, I mean, I get it.
Entrepreneurship is, it sucks.
I've been through all the hard times too.
And I'm sure a lot of you guys have it worse.
And people have had it way worse than me.
Way worse than you too.
I got an S.
Ha ha.
I had eight kills, four deaths.
Jarai's had six kills, seven deaths.
And we won.
So the streak continues.
Yes, the streak continues.
The streak continues.
All right.
So, Rishi thought to close us off with
words of wisdom.
Rishi thought of the day is.
I will just say that
it is,
that no one,
cup of, cup of you.
Cup of you.
And what I mean by that.
Yeah, cup of you.
And that like so, so much of these questions today
still come back to, you know,
really being aware of what it is that you want to do
and taking action on that.
So I know that's simple, but it's true.
Cup of you.
Cup of you, I love it.
Well, thank you guys so much for watching.
It's been great to have you here.
I hope you guys go out and enjoy the rest of your Tuesday.
Go make something amazing happen.
We believe in you.
So we hope that you continue to believe,
or cup, or whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you soon.